4日
私を機はそれがとても広いんです
例えばこれ
普段使っている限りの誰かなんですが決して小さいものではありません
これを家でも会社でも出先でも1日に5回はどこかに置き忘れて俺の鍵見なかった
毎日いろいろな人に聞きまわっています
ちなみにこの会場に着いてからすでに3回鍵を託しています
1回鍵を探すのはに10分はかかりますから
1日5回で50分
それが家でも会社でも365日ですから
年間約300時間
実に1年のうち12日間以上私は鍵を探し続けている計算になります
おかげで兄がいたもののなかなか探す時間もとれず未だに
33歳独身ですねこれ
私は苦手なものはもう一つあります
私
人の機嫌を損ねるのがとてもトピアです
これも特に女性
先日久しぶりに会った同世代の女性にこう言いました
なんかしばらく見ないうちに
すごい化粧がうまくなったね
知り合うことに
彼女は無言で無表情でした
込めたはずなのにん
でも空気の夢よ私もさすがに気づきましたこれはもしかしたら
お世辞だと思ってがっかりするんじゃないかと
もっと心を込めてようなきゃっだからなん
お世辞なんかじゃないよ
本当には行った時は別人の良くなかった
化粧が国なんだまるで決勝だけじゃないみたいだんっ
ちなみに貼る下は全くありません
ん
その私の毎日のように鍵を置き忘れ続けるであるとか
毎日のように女性を怒らせてばかりになるとかこれは
私が働く福祉の世界ではとても苦手とはまた別の言い方があります
極度のを矯正の多さは周囲血管障害
通称 adb
人の気持ちが推測できず怒らせてばかりなのは
自閉症スペクトラム通称 a 3
このんだつをざっくりまとめて発達障害って
ゆったりします
ここで皆さんにちょうど確かめてのチームとがあります
今私は
自分自身のとても苦手なことについて
話をしているでしょうか
それとも
自分自身の半たつ障害について告白をしているところなんでしょうか
今皆さんはどちらに感じられていますか
私の話の
生涯とても苦手の境目ってどこにあるでしょう
ここで2つ質問があります
必ず心の中で手を挙げてください
一つ目
私は障害を持っているという方
心の中で手を挙げてください
ありがとうございます
もう一つ
私にはとても苦手なことがあるという方心の中で手を挙げてください
ありがとうございます
心のでが見えました
あの
その時障害を持っている
いうことに手を開けた方はおそらく少数です
でもとても苦手なことがあるに入ってを挙げたのはこの会場のほとんどすべての方では
ないでしょうか
この時の
皆さんが手を挙げた明確な散布障害と苦手の境目って明らかなんでしょうか
この時皆さんが今日上げた時に負けたのは障害がある側の
障がいがある方とそうではないがはの自分かもしれません
障害者とそうではないローの自分を開ける社会面で皆さんどこにあるでしょうか
考えたことは
ありますか
福祉では
iq が70以下であれば知的障害という定義があります
しかしここで皆さんに考えて頂きたいのは定義の話ではなく
あなた自身が
どこをどう判断して誰かを
障害者だと感じ
自分を障害者ではないと思う
捉えに言うのでしょう
定期通り iq 70以下の知的障害の iq 70時間の方を見たら
知的障害だと思う
皆さんは感じるでしょうか
それでしたら
iq の価値10%を超えるアインシュタインから見て
私たちは知的なハンディを抱えているように見えないでしょうか
同じように
100メートルを9行58電子るウサインボルトから見て
そこから5秒以上遅れてゴールする私達は
心体的なハンディを抱えているように見えないでしょうか
あるいは私は
1年のうち何時間以上鍵を置き忘れ続ければそれは障害になるでしょう
私は1年のうち女性を怒らせるのを何回かに抑えればそれを張ったつ紹介ではなく
とても苦手と言っていいでしょ
私は
障害者なんでしょうか
皆さんどう感じていますか
私の答えは no です
私は障害者ではありません
私は毎日のように鍵を置き忘れ続け
毎日のように女性の機嫌を超えたばかり言うだけの
一人の任命です
私は
障害者のっていう人は後
この世界のどこにもいないと思っています
今この瞬間も障害者と呼ばれている人たちは
あなたたちとあなたと同じく何がとても苦手なことを持つ
一人ひとりです
障害者いう人はこの世界のどこにも存在しない
では
障害って一体どこにあるでしょ
考えたことはありますか
バリアフリーという言葉があります
そのバリアは
そのあたりの道路にダンサーとして存在をしているわけでもなければ
障害者と呼ばれている人たちが抱えているものでもありません
本来はとてもとてもあいまいなぁ
障害ととても苦手いる
その間に無意識に明確な線をサポートする試み
例えば
支援を
されるがはこう支援をする側
無条件に手を差し伸べるべき側と
閉塞自己責任のがあ
かわいそうな川とへ恵まれた彼は
時には無条件に純粋服であり善人であるばとそうではないがは
その間に一人一人が無意識に
引こうとしているその性こそが私は唯一
障害と呼べるものだと思っています
私は長年の車いすの友人とこんなやり取りをします
おい編タイプな数字さん
これは彼と一緒に買い物に行ったとき
海峡して横で後ろからレジの女の子に向かって
お姉ちゃん可愛いですね
急に声を掛ければですね
一緒に買い物をしている横で急に何防止出す
友人に
変態ということに皆さん色がないんですよね
1本で私が web かを見てください多いもリアル
ホットが入ってみろと言われることもあります
これどちらも
心体的な特徴盟友子だね
といいなんです
もしかしたらそのやり取りを見で私が彼を変態車いすお姉ちゃんと呼んでいるのを見て
何か周りの人が感じているかもしれません
でも私と海との間には遮るものは何もありません
これだけは
確かです
そんな彼らが私に教えてくれたことがあります
自分の生涯
自分のハンディキャップ
自分のとても苦手なこと
言い方なんて何でもいいんです
私たじゃあそこのゲーム私たちすべてが何かとても苦手なこと
ハンディキャップを持つ
一人ひとりです
そしてその誰もが自分のとても苦手なことについて
他の誰かのサポートを受けています
そうですよね
たとえ直接
手を差し伸べられていなくても
自分のとても苦手なことについて仕方ないなぁ
受け入れてくれフォローしてくれている方が
みなさんの周りに必ずいるはずです
私たちをすべて
自分のとても苦手なところを抱え
それを彼の誰かにサポートされ
なんとか生きています
なんとか
それを
障害者と呼ぶのであれば私たちは皆
障害者です
おっ
どうか
確かめてみてください
そこには
竹べき一戦も
取り除くべき障害もならすべき
段差も
高圧べき壁も
最初から
たんです
ありがとうございました4
[拍手]